[Music]
hey everyone Ashley Carlson here with a
spoiler-free review of Disney's newest
animated feature Moana we said of course
to find a brand new island everywhere we
roll
the story goes like this
sixteen-year-old mallanna is the future
chief of her tribe but when something
bigger calls to her she must pair up
with legendary demigod Maui and travel
across the sea and attempt to sleep with
people the ocean is a friend of mine the
artistry and animation that went into
this movie is breathtaking the colors
the ocean the hair the details it must
be seen on the big screen
I'll give me
lin-manuel Miranda of Hamilton fame was
a collaborator on the soundtrack so
don't just expect beautiful music expect
to be borderline addicted to the
soundtrack don't mess well now we win
he's on a breakaway and the tapestry
here in my skin is enough of the
pictures i win and bring tissues to the
theater because there are so many feels
I think the morale of wanna of
journeying to find yourself is such an
important message that parents can take
away from just as well as your kids can
and plenty of laughs when you use a bird
to write with it's called tweeting yeah
the cool thing about Disney and the deep
dive research that they did and how
authentic they really wanted to make the
movie that's what I love everything
about this movie feels genuinely
authentic from the casting to the music
you can really feel that in the heart
and soul of mawana this is a culture
that doesn't see themselves on screen
very much and you want them to be able
to point at this movie with pride from
the musical perspective you know Mike
one of my co-writers oppa ty foi who is
an amazing songwriter and ambassador for
his culture and everything that comes
out of him sounds like the island so
from a musical perspective all rhythms
begin with him all the harmonies and
stuff sort of emanate from him so if you
can't tell i'm in love with millana that
was almost a straight up ad but i hope
we get to hear some of these songs
performed at the oscars wouldn't it be
great check it out when it hits theaters
on the twenty-third and when you're done
let me know your thoughts
[Music]
you